morning everyone with trust has come
under Fire from our own MPS in a meeting
with Tori back benches known as the 1922
committee she's told them to give her
government more credit after committing
once more not to cut public spending as
trust is facing growing pressure for
another policy reversal and was accused
of trashing the last 10 years of the
tourist record at a bruising meeting of
the 22 committee and in Washington her
Chancellor quasi quateng will today try
to reassure the IMF that everyone and
everything is under control after the
institute's chief Economist said tax
cuts threatened to cause problems for
the UK economy joining us now is the
foreign secretary James Cleveland okay
good to see you this morning thanks for
joining us
um she had another bruising day
yesterday actually going to turn this
around well look the Prime Minister when
she was running for the leadership of
the party made it clear that she felt
that we needed to bring taxation levels
down from the 70-year high that we're
currently looking at not put taxes up
further than they already are to make
sure we have growth in the economy and
to ensure that Ukraine is successful in
defending itself against Russia She is
delivering on all those feet on all
those three things
um and what she was saying to the 22 I
wasn't actually in the meeting but what
I know she said to the 1922 is that you
know we've got to make sure that we help
people keep more of the earnings in
their own Pockets that we've got to be
good custodians of the public purse but
we've got to grow the economy that's
what she's pushing for I think those are
our solid traditional conservative
governmental principles and I think we
should stick with it so you're going to
stick with a mini budget well the uh the
the last time we spoke we talked about
the changes that the uh uh the
chancellor has met had made to one of
the elements of it but ultimately what
that mini budget was about we should
remind ourselves it was about protecting
tens of millions of people from
unaffordable Energy prices so that was
the bulk of that proposal it was about
making sure that taxes for 30 million
working people were reduced a little bit
uh and those are really strong
principles and I absolutely think we
should stick with those okay so there'll
be no other changes there'd be no more
reversals on what happened well the uh
the chance
so the chancellor is going to be making
a statement on the 31st of October which
gives a more holistic uh assessment of
the public finances and our response to
the the global headwinds that every uh
democracy well every democracy every
economy in the world is facing but as I
say the the the the the foundations that
mini budget protecting people from
Energy bill prices letting them keep
more of their earnings protecting
businesses from those Energy prices
making sure that we're internationally
competitive all those things are really
key for the growth agenda that the prime
minister's put forward sticking with
corporation tax or not well I I mean the
chancellor the chancellor will come to
the uh to the dispatch box I think it's
absolutely right that we've made it
clear that we want to invest in
businesses and and when people talk
about you know taxing businesses I think
sometimes there's this idea that they're
some faceless entities these are people
these are employees these are these are
the organizations that help people pay
their bills and actually they have been
under huge amount of pressure I talked
to businesses in my constituency they
have really felt the pressure and it's
absolutely right that we help them stay
competitive we help them stay afloat
that we help them uh uh compete
internationally employ people and pay
better wages and that's the kind of
thing that we should be doing and that's
why uh as I say the the package the
chancellor put forward is pro-growth and
is the right answer so you're sticking
with that then the chairman of the
education committee uh Robert Halford
um has been speaking in the 1922
committee as you know apparently he says
that Liz truss is trashing working-class
conservatism she's losing the back
benches unless she changes some of the
policies that she put forward as part of
the mini budget well look let's let's
remind ourselves what the proposition uh
put forward by the prime minister is she
says that first and foremost many of
these issues are Amplified by Putin's
brutal invasion of Ukraine and we need
to help the ukrainians defend their
defend their country we saw in the vote
in the United Nations last night we've
got an International Coalition of
condemnation against Russia in support
of Ukraine so support Ukraine 0.1 bring
taxes down a bit from their 70-year tax
burden high and grow the economy so that
we can pay for the Public Services if
people are saying one of those three
things are wrong I'll be very keen to
find out which of the those three things
people saying Adventures you have to
convince well again but let me look at
this quote look at this tweet it says um
Tori MP it was from one of my colleagues
at the Daily Mail Tori mp on let's try
this appearance at the 1922 committee it
was like someone trying to light a fire
using a magnifying glass using damp wood
in the dark these are the people that
she needs on side to get her policies
through yeah well look I mean some
people uh some people like having
quotable tweets and some people like
delivering good government I'm in the
camp of the kind of people that like
delivering good government I know that
the chancellor the Prime Minister and my
ministerial colleagues our focus on
delivering for the British people
if you don't want the tweets let's go
with Paul Johnson the ifs director try
as hard as we can given plausible
forecasts we can't see how to get public
finances on a sustainable path without
big painful spending cuts or a reversal
of the 43 billion pound tax cuts just
announced
well we have got to grow the economy
growing the economy is the way for well
growth The Way We Grow the economy is to
make sure we are internationally
competitive I'm the foreign secretary I
travel around the world and I can see
other countries you know tax and
Regulatory regimes and we have got to
make sure we compete internationally
with the uh with the other places that
people and businesses could choose to
locate so we've got to make sure that we
are tax competitive we've got to make
sure we are uh uh pro-growth that's why
the investment zones are so very very
important that's why making sure that we
don't have an unpredictable tax regime
which is why giving predictability for
people and businesses about tax is so
very very important because when you
grow the economy you can afford to fund
the Public Services on which we all rely
the Prime Minister has been clear that
we are going to fund Public Services
properly she's already made strong
announcements about the NHS about
increasing defense spending and other
areas but we have to be good cast
stadiums of the public person yes public
money is your monies your viewers money
it's not my money yeah to keep stepping
in to try to save our economy at the
moment Ian Duncan Smith is furious about
that formatory leader he's described
Andrew Bailey as stupid and the measures
that he has put forward as a mess do you
agree with him well look I I very much
value the independence of the bank of
England that means we've got to let them
do their job their job part of that part
of their job no of course he's not you
don't get to be you don't get to be
governor of the bank of England uh if
you're being stupid
um but the point is the the job of the
bank of England is to intervene it's
part of the strong institutions that
make the UK such an attractive offer
around the world he is doing his uh he's
doing his job doesn't mean we always
agree with everything the bank of
England Governor says or does uh from a
personal point of view and Ian's totally
totally entitled to his view but he's
there for a reason the bank is there for
a reason they're doing the job job that
they do they're independent we've got to
let them get on with them but if you
want the Fig if you want to grow the
economy by two and a half percent which
is what you say has to happen in order
for these figures to work then how's
that going to happen given that the IMF
has said that the worst is yet to come
and for many people 2023 will feel like
a recession well we've seen the labor
party trying to uh you know trying to
create no trying to create this this
negative narrative but but the point is
if you actually look at the figures if
you look at the figures what you've seen
is that
um earlier on in this year when we were
predicted to have negative growth we
actually had Positive Growth the
inflation figures that were predicted
we've come in lower those inflation
figures we've got lower inflation than
many of our competitors we have got
um uh interest rates which although
they're going up they're going up slower
than many of our International
competitors
every economy in the world is facing a
really really tough time I understand
yes 0.3 is the prediction for next year
but the point is that you can't look at
those you can't look at those growth
figures and say we want bigger growth
figures than that and then criticize
every measure that drives growth you
can't look at those and this is why we
talk about the anti-growth Coalition
because there are people that point to
that growth and so it's not high enough
and when the Prime Minister comes
forward and says we should do this this
and this to boost growth they oppose all
those things as well and you can't have
it both ways why are the markets so
concerned about what the budget said the
mini budget well we we've put in the
media last time no I didn't no I didn't
no I absolutely didn't God I absolutely
didn't the point that I put the the
point that we have been consistent about
is we have got to take the action that
grows the economy that means change
change we completely understand can
sometimes be on sale when you've had you
know a decade-long uh way of doing
business way of doing government and the
Prime Minister comes along and says I'm
going to do things differently of course
that triggers a reaction but as I say
defending helping the ukrainians defend
themselves growing the economy going for
growth these things are absolutely core
to a conservative guy but if the back
benches say she's wrong if the IMF says
she's wrong if the uh Bank of England
says she's wrong if the market says
she's wrong surely
so I come back to the point I've made if
you at our core the core of what the
prime minister is saying is that we need
to be internationally competitive we
need to have growth in our economy and
we need to address some of the issues
that are driving uh these pressures the
war in Ukraine are over Reliance on
dictatorial regimes like Russia for
energy Supply in Europe these things we
need to address and it's all well and
goodness and again and we saw this the
other night with regards to votes and
the late party they're very very
critical but when we when when it comes
to putting forward an alternative no
alternative comes forward okay so going
budget will double down on what we've
already heard what we will come what we
will stay consistent with yeah is the
plan to grow the economy to protect
people from those Rising energy bills to
support the ukrainians defending
themselves against Russia to address
some of the international drivers for
the difficulties let me ask you that
we're all facing we're at on you know
we're running out of me asking another
couple of questions the India trade deal
they're not at all happy with what the
Home Secretary has said she said I do
have some reservations look at migration
in this country the largest group of
people who overstay are Indian migrants
as I said the Indians not at all happy
about that comment how will you fix that
next time you're there well we do have a
very strong relationship with uh India
the people and of course the Indian
government uh one of the I mean one of
the Hallmarks of a strong relationship
is you can have a very straight talking
conversation I met with the Indian
foreign minister my opposite number just
a few weeks ago we were able to talk
very very frankly and of course we do
want to have an even stronger and this
is strong already but an even stronger
trading relationship with India we want
to make sure
today well look the the point of view
you wouldn't have said it would you so
the points of being the foreign minister
is my job to to make sure the
relationship works on every level for
both countries that's exactly the
conversational that's exactly the
conversation I have when I when I when I
speak with the uh Representatives the
Indian government in the future do you
think that Queen Camilla should wear the
Karina or Diamond when she is crying
well ultimately decisions like that are
for the palace what I have seen actually
um through the funeral arrangements for
late Majesty is the palace is really
very good at assessing the the public
and indeed the international mood
ultimately of course the decisions are
for for the the palace on issues like
this
um
well look we we have a fantastic
relationship with uh with with India and
Indian people and as I say you know it's
a decision for the palace
um and I have no doubt the coronation
will be an absolute celebration okay
final question before we let you go do
you support Harry Kane and the fa's
decision to wear a rainbow armband
um in Qatar for the World Cup well I
think that we stand by our values I
think the England football team stands
by the values of their home nation
they're a part of the UK we feel very
strongly about this I've had
conversations with the qataris about the
World Cup about our values well look um
again these are decisions for the fa and
individual uh footballers they need to
know that they've got their foreign
secretary behind them so the point is I
absolutely will support their our
national football team they're in an
international competition I want them to
win I've already said to the qataris I
very very much look forward to seeing
England uh in the final I can't remember
quite how these stages work out if it
could be England and Wales that'll be
even better still
um but uh would you wonder if it was
it's good to see you always thank you
very much indeed thank you